de jonquière comment expliquez-vous le
set à paris en 1965 que france nadeau
commence sa carrière comme journaliste
pigiste pour radio-canada et les
accompagne son mari pierre nadeau nommé
correspondant dans la capitale française
et le public est très enthousiaste
vraiment des bravos fusent
elle fait notamment des entrevues avec
des personnalités du monde des arts
visuels et de la chanson comme le
peintre catalan salvador dali des de
vous que vous êtes un petr pompiers
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un peintre
pompier au bénin et la chanteuse pauline
julien une émission couleurs de radio
canada
le vieux montréal est le quartier
historique de la métropole du canada
quelques années plus tard elle rejoint
l'équipe de l'émission femme
d'aujourd'hui qui a marqué l'histoire de
la télévision et du féminisme au québec
pendant près de dix ans comme
journaliste et co animatrice avec aline
desjardins
elle couvre une panoplie de sujets l
interview notamment l'écrivain
montréalais de renommée internationale
mordecai richler
chaque fois journalistes et animateurs
winston mcquade a bien connue celle avec
qui il a collaboré à plusieurs occasions
une journaliste qui avait une ouverture
sur le monde
elle était intéressée par
l'international c'est sa curiosité
ce désir d'aller au fond des choses
d'apporter de l'eau au moulin si on veut
de la culture qui a fait d'elle une
journaliste y était quand à moi
remarquable france nadeau sera dans les
années 80 journaliste animatrice des
chroniqueuses de nombreuses émissions de
radio canada comme reflet d'un pays
au fil de la semaine et au jour le jour
je pense pas que ce soit un cas
classique mais dans mon cas c'est tout à
fait par hasard elle était une pionnière
du winston mcquade à une époque qui
n'était pas toujours facile pour les
femmes et je trouve que radio-canada à
cette époque là ne faisait pas la part
très belle aux femmes dans le domaine de
l'information et dans le domaine des
médias en général ce que disait un homme
c'était sérieux
c'était évidemment on le croyait c'était
mais quand c'était ça venait d'une femme
on savait pas trop quoi faire avec ça
les temps heureusement changé france
nadeau laisse dans le deuil son fils
sylvain et sa fille notre collègue la
journaliste et animatrice pascale nadeau
ainsi que cinq petits enfants ici
alexandre à chaska radio canada montréal